so what do you miss most about you know
Boston after coming down to Southern
California I miss uh Seasons
um I love fall love fall and I'll also
love early winter and I love
um
wearing a coat outside because
um it makes me feel like I look better
when I'm wearing a coat and uh we all
have some feelings about body dysmorphia
or whatever I just like me when I'm
wearing a coat
and I look for any excuse to wear a coat
and if I could wear a parka in La I
would so I I don't know it's always been
I like going back to Boston I'm going to
go back there to see my family still
lives there I'll go back uh for
Thanksgiving and that's the part I'm
looking forward to is it being cold
outside and me wearing a coat that
breaks up the fact that I'm
three-quarters leg and uh I have a very
short disproportional torso and um I
think I didn't mean to go yeah yeah
sorry but seriously I I love it you put
on a you know when I put on a pea coat
you know I'm just like this hey that
guy's real tall and yeah that guy is uh
well no one's really saying that no one
is saying that I know I don't know what
you're talking about well anyway I like
I like Seasons I miss Seasons a lot and
um I love The Walking culture here I
mean there in Boston uh you when you
walk around here
um people think that you're mentally ill
if you're walking and it's like
depressing that if I decide I'm just
gonna walk and I'm gonna walk to that to
that drugstore to that CVS that's 15
blocks from here
yeah oh my God I like to stretch the
legs you know what I'm saying but people
think something's things you know that
that's what it's like here in Los
Angeles if someone's on the street
they they think uh that that you've be
something terrible has happened to Conan
O'Brien he's wandering the streets and
it's like you know that will happen but
it hasn't happened yet and I that's so
that's those are some of the things that
I miss it dips below 60 here that's cold
I can't no it's not at home that's
really cool no it's not cold we talk
about this all the time and you're like
I hate it I hate it it's 65. I can't
stand it it's it's no it's not cold your
tolerance for the cold has probably
changed though like if you go back in
the winter
no I'd never make that noise I would
never I learned
[Music]
well that's where it tends to go why
yeah I don't know